hello my friends its silver rat again
and today I'm going to finish this this
kind right now kind of crappy station
but I hope I can turn it into something
better than it it's now and yes just
some cool news I got a new headset so
I'm using that right now so it's a bit
better boy it's supposed to have noise
cancelling that's what Logitech said at
least but I can't yeah I can't really
hear that I just hear well terrible
noise and then my voice bit soft and the
noise is pretty much killing my ears but
luckily I got audacity with the filter
things so I can filter that after I've
recorded so I'm going to do that because
the quality is slightly higher than my
old headset and I've got my old headset
right next to me right here and it's
ugly it's really ugly I kind of
demolished that thing it's very dirty
and it's falling apart so that's why I'm
using a different one now but anyway my
my PC is cooking right now it's crazy so
I guess I'll get to work
you know what I actually like this
building I didn't I didn't expect me to
say this but in the end it actually
turned out to be pretty cool I'm not too
sure though about one thing it doesn't
see it doesn't seem that steampunky or
medieval is too much of Alpine
influences all over the place I mean up
until this height it's pretty decent
because I've got all my a steampunk
stuff and cool ironworks over here but
then the roof I just didn't have
anything else to do that so I had to use
alpine village so now it I don't know
but altogether this building actually
looks really cool and I might just use
that Alpine style bit more because after
all you can't have castles everywhere
that's not what the medieval times like
now what the cool idea or at least I'm
not sure if it's cool idea but the idea
I had was to get this medieval town kind
of style with a lot of wood and stuff
and mix that with a steampunk so like
the iron example in here but this
building is not that steampunk ish other
buildings will be more steampunk but at
least that's what I'll try and I've no
clue how it if it if it's actually going
to work out but that's my plan at least
and all that's left to do here next well
before I can do all the rock work and
support work that is is finish this path
and at a building over here now the one
problem is that my laptop right now is
so hot that I can't even that what I can
touch it but I would rather not I would
like to keep my limbs so I'm not doing
that
so yeah I'm cutting it off here so I'm
not doing anything else this episode so
next episode we'll be finishing the path
ending a little building or knots in
here because you know it's kind of tight
just like in here but I figured
something out and then I'll finally
themelis go so I'm actually looking
forward to theming this coaster to be
honest I usually don't like doing
awkward but whenever I've got stuff with
tunnels and inverts like I did with
Valhalla I I don't know but I like that
I like it a lot more than they're you
know coasters that don't have any
interaction with the ground or foliage
in any way so I'm looking forward to
that so see you next episode